- No, I'm just kind of
discovering filters now.
They make you look so tan.
(fun music)
- So, when I first got Instagram,
I thought it was just a photo editing app.
I didn't realize it was a social network.
So I was just going on an
editing pictures for funsies.
Here's my first one.
Paperclips.
It might have been my phone
background for a hot minute.
- I post pretty often and I'd say that
I've gone through several
phases with how I use Instagram.
It's called "dART" because
it's dartboard with a Coca Cola can.
This is when I started
incorporating branding,
so people know I'm open for sponsorship.
- Definitely. Did it work?
- No.
- Very first one is,
I was drunk and I just
wrote a caption that says,
"be afraid, be very afraid."
And I guess I was trying to scare people
that I was on Instagram.
- (host) What is that?
- An umbrella.
- (host) Are you sure it's an umbrella,
it looks like one of those tiki umbrellas
that you put in your drink.
- It wasn't the cheapy plastic umbrellas
from the Dollar Store.
It was one of those table umbrellas
at the University of Miami.
And I was just sitting
there bored, I guess.
And I was like, hmm, time to take a photo.
- Art is everywhere.
- It got two likes.
- For those of you who can't tell,
there's milk in the Brita pitcher.
- Gross.
- One drunken night I accidentally,
not accidentally, I obviously
did this on purpose,
I have no recollection, but,
I poured milk into a Brita pitcher.
- Okay, so, I though Instagram at first
was a filter app.
Like, specifically just
to filter things, so,
my friend was like "hey,
you got a long board?"
and I was like "Yeah, I'm
a cool kid in college,
I got a long board."
So, I literally took the photo thinking
only it would save,
I didn't know any of my
first photos were here
for the world to see.
But, the thirst was very real for like,
first years of college stuff.
Like, dry as the Sahara dessert,
I wanna find me a woman thirsty.
- Okay.
- Oh my god, this is so embarrassing.
- Another bad one of me with a basic plant
but I only put in focus one of my eyes.
It was a real fun way to use it.
- Yeah.
- But, now, it's really
just my actual life.
(fun music)
- Hi.
- Oh, hey guys.
Sarah, over here.
We made a series.
- It's coming out November 18th.
- Please watch it.
- Get it here.
- There.
- Over there.
- You got it.
- If you look in the
area, then you can see.
It will be released 2015, November.
Okay.